In a busy world, with endless work and responsibilities that accumulate,
Stress can affect us better.
But how bad is it for us, really? Can stress kill you?
From a biological perspective, stress seems quite logical.
If you are about to bite off a bear, it is best for stress hormones to let you go for alertness.
But it turns out that your mortgage, unemployment, exam is looming
All of them move the same response to stress in your body.
Unlike most animals,
Which eventually faced a significant reduction in these hormones,
Human beings do not seem to be able to find a stop button!
Although it is not life or death challenges,
We have psychological problems that constantly lead to the dumping of our bodies with these hormones,
Which leads to heart palpitations and tight muscles tense and upset stomach.
In Japan, they have the term Karoshi, which literally translates to "death from exhaustion".
In what is now considered an epidemic of fatigue,
These people who are apparently healthy and young, suddenly die.
This situation was officially recognized and documented in Japan,
These sudden heart attacks and strokes were quickly linked to stress.
But how can this stress cause?
Cortisol is one of the main stress hormones, and it helps to convert energy to where you need it
Away from the non-essential functions of the body.
But with exposure to chronic stress, problems arise.
The immune system stops functioning, turns into inflammation, and white blood cells drop
The susceptibility to the disease increases.
Some evidence also suggests that prolonged stress can be involved in the development of cancer.
When looking at the arteries of macaque monkeys, which are under great pressure, they have more clogged arteries
This prevents blood from reaching the heart quickly during stress,
It can eventually lead to heart attacks.
The brain is also exposed to losses. When looking at rat-prone stress, we see it
Brain cells are significantly smaller, with fewer branches than normal mice. and this is
Particularly in areas associated with memory and learning.
Which may raise some memories for you for all those evening sessions.
Stress and severe sleep deprivation can make it difficult for us to remember the things you want to remember more and more.
Perhaps the most telling story is in DNA.
We own the so-called telomere at the end of our chromosomes,
Which decreases in size with age. Our video on "Aging", here, explains the process.
Eventually, the telomeres break down, and at this point the cell stops repeating and dies
Thus telomeres are directly related to aging and longevity.
Stress has been shown to accelerate the shortening of these telomeres.
But do not lose your hopes for chronic stress.
Another hormone, oxytocin, is found to limit response to stress.
It also helps blood vessels relax, and even renews the heart from stress-related damage.
So how do we get more oxytocin? Sometimes called "Hormone Hormone",
Because it spurs through positive social interactions and attention to others.
People who spend more time with others create a buffer or ability to adapt to stress.
So when life bothers you, just remember, you do not have to face it alone.
Spend some time with someone you love - you may save your life!
Do you have a pressing question you want to answer? Type it in comments, or on Facebook and Twitter.
And if you want to get to know the next episode ideas behind the scenes,
Check out Instagram and Twitter. Subscribe to more weekly science videos!